ja die suche nach den vermissten ist in
diesem chaos natürlich extrem schwierig
an den straßenrändern türmen sich
überall meter hohe trümmerberge
so wie hier im hintergrund und das ist
eine mischung aus nassem schlamm aus
abfall und ausgerollt und natürlich muss
man befürchten dass sich unter diesen
trümmern
auch opfer der katastrophe befinden
jetzt kann man natürlich nicht einfach
hergehen und das meter für meter
abtragen sondern hier kommen speziell
ausgebildete leichenspürhunde zum
einsatz und die werden gerade aus allen
teilen deutschlands ins
katastrophengebiet gebracht wissen wie
läuft eine suche mit den hunden dann
genau ab ja wir konnten eine
spezialeinheit aus sachsen-anhalt
begleiten die hat neun hunde dabei und
die sind hier sechseinhalb stunden mit
dem auto her gefahren und in der praxis
muss man sich das so vorstellen dass der
hund mit seinem hundeführer an den
stellen eingesetzt wird an denen es noch
vermisste gibt und die suche ist für den
hund eine regelrechte strapaze es ist
extrem anstrengend und deshalb kann ein
tier auch nur für 20 bis maximal 25
minuten in den trümmern eingesetzt
werden dann ist der hund völlig
erschöpft und braucht erstmal eine pause
das ist anstrengend für den hund ich
könnte mir aber auch vorstellen ist es
gefährlich durch diesen ganzen schon
irgendwie sich durch zu wühlen als hund
am die gefährlich ist es tatsächlich für
die tiere
ja es ist tatsächlich sehr gefährlich
denn wir gehen mal ein bisschen näher
ran der kollege hinter der kamera der
zeigt uns das mal dass ich hier
hauptsächlich nasa schlamm das ist
extrem glitschig die tiere finden hier
mit ihren pfoten überhaupt keinen halt
die rutschen immer ab und was noch dazu
kommt man weiß natürlich auch gar nicht
was ist hier überhaupt alles drunter
hier können nägel darunter seien scharfe
kanten oder glasscherben und da können
sich die tiere verletzen es gibt
natürlich spezielle gummi schuhe für
hunde
die kommen hier aber nicht zum einsatz
und zwar aus dem einfachen grund die
würden sehr schnell mit wasser und mit
schlamm volllaufen und dann können sich
die tiere überhaupt nicht mehr richtig
bewegen so was jetzt passieren kann ist
die tiere verletzen sich an den pfoten
es gibt schnitte die können sich auch
sehr schnell entzünden denn der
hundeführer kann wegen dieser dicken
schlamm kruste die verletzung überhaupt
gar nicht so schnell erkennen
ein hundeführer der sagte uns zb ja also
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich überhaupt gar
nicht wie ich den hund nachher sauber
machen soll und er hat sich überlegt
dass ihr hund dann vielleicht in einen
see springt damit sich wenigstens die
dickste kruste lösen kann
ganz herzlichen dank an dieser bastian
prange
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren